...
-AYA, AYA, AYA
AYA, AYA, AYA
AYA, AYA
-La muraille
Tremble et se fend
Comme un coeur qui éclate en deux
Et la femme
Entre dans l'histoire
Comme arrive l'oeuvre d'un Dieu
L'homme né sans mémoire
Reconnaît l'Eve qu'il veut
Brise l'avenir
Et nous fait monter aux yeux
Les sanglots
Le péché leur fait chaud
Dieu que c'est beau
...
-AYA, AYA, AYA
-Oh que c'est beau
AYA, AYA
-La muraille
Penche et se tord
Pour faire un toit aux amoureux
Et la femme
Au ventre arrondi
Se remplit d'un nouveau feu
L'homme sur l'avenir
Met ses mains et fait un voeu
Eve doit souffrir
Pour faire naître sous nos yeux
Le héros
Qui sort sous les bravos
Dieu que c'est beau
...
-AYA, AYA, AYA
-Oh que c'est beau
-C'est de l'amour
Et le fruit du péché est très beau
L'enfant crie
Tue le serpent
L'ordre est nouveau
Lève la foule
Et admire l'enfant sorti des eaux
La terre tourne
Oh Dieu que c'est beau
-AYA, AYA, AYA
-Oh que c'est beau
-Oh que, que c'est beau
-AYA, AYA, AYA
-Oh que c'est beau
Que c'est beau
-AYA, AYA, AYA
-Oh que c'est beau